hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and the kipster
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
page that way you get the videos
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u garbage it's the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grew up classy or
if they're a big old piece of do-do
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day
down here aunt toddy's basement on a
saturday
you gotta love it baby the sauce is ragu
and the prescriptions are all generic
my co-host coming at you from right next
to me he's the uh the guy who put this
whole thing together he's the elon musk
are you garbage it's got a corvette out
there in space somewhere with a guy
sitting in it
give it up for kippy kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube those
numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
thank you very much also you know the
bread and butter what pays the bills
www.patreon.com bonus content
are you garbage you get bonus episodes
bonus videos we're gonna be doing a live
stream at the end of the month
where we get to play with are you
garbage with you guys you can ask
questions
it's gonna be a big old family [ __ ]
patty so
check it out and we got good stuff on
there good content yeah for the first
one we called our moms the second one
probably made me have milk with dinner
uh plus some bonus videos some bonus
videos
i just posted a video yeah he just
posted a video all butthole
yeah also uh we got merch go to
podcastgates.com
let's take a second let's tip our hat to
our old pal our producer extraordinaire
the very funny
the very confident the very cool the
magic man toby mcmullen
t-bone what's up t-bone the big t back
here
working the ones and twos but gang
that's all neither here
nor there we got scotland for the
[ __ ] business we are to do at 2 4
here today
and that is we could not be more excited
to have our incredibly incredibly
special guest
here with us this afternoon this man is
a very successful very funny stand-up
comedian
actor and writer as an actor he has
appeared in hardest job in sports
vanilla and the chris kethered presents
as a writer he's written on the break
with michelle wolf
and he was also the co-host and writer
for people talking sports and other
stuff with sam morrell
as a welder
are you giving up the reveal for you
dummy what's the matter with you
he has an amazing one-man show that he
can't wait to get back uh
up and doing once the pandemic's over
called my dad isn't danny devito
he has an album out called dream
occupation and as a stand-up comedian
kids got a quite as amazing this young
man has performed on gotham comedy live
comedians in public
adam devine's house party late show with
stephen colbert he has his own comedy
central presents
and he just did the stand-up show with
john doerr but the big question in
everybody's mind today
does he work for the imperial star wars
you're right i do
one of the fine senators of naboo this
guy's a big mandalorian fan
full and bust guard gang do me a favor
give it up for the precautious
the very funny the very talented the
absolutely amazing
mr anthony devito thank you so much man
what an intro
thanks for coming buddy that mask i love
it i get it
if you're not aware new york we got a
little spike going on over here
so we're all taking extra precautions
everything's been sanitized down we wore
masks up until
up until now and anthony's going one
step further protecting us
and protecting you the viewers with his
with his face shield
yeah it's for you guys at home we don't
know how far this virus can travel
and it could get into the wires you
could find it in your kitchen
the headphones is what does it mean you
gotta look crazy
yeah there's so many things happening
around my face
right now but here's the thing if this
was like he's got so many accessories on
manny i feel like a guy at the met
gallery
if this was like 1983 and you were at a
college party
you'd be crushing everything what kind
of
[ __ ] college did you go to i mean
like you know like the whole nerd wave
of the early 80s what do you mean i
don't know it looks like he's in uh
that kid he walked into a college party
what are you talking about if you've
watched this kind of guy
i'd argue with you you wouldn't i think
you'd be sort of afraid what's the ban
that's singing
he's got plutonium
the libyans
that might be gaddafi from the future
that's what i would say i think time
travel was so prevalent in the 80s yeah
sure it was a hot position hot button i
think you would be like
we got ourselves a time traveler we're
talking about talking about like devo
and stuff like that oh i see oh yeah
sure that was very niche
i could definitely be in a german pop
band i think for sure
could be spinning records in ibiza
anthony thank you so much for sitting in
with us thank you so much for being here
um of course give us the original story
i know it's a little interesting you're
a jersey kid
i am i grew up in uh north jersey um in
essex county i grew up in the same town
where the last scene of the sopranos was
shot there very very italian
uh area i found out a very very big
italian family i was raised my household
was my mom
my grandma uh my great grandmother one
of my aunts
and myself all the same houses same
house was it like broken up into
apartments
no one whole house we lived in one
leather shoe um
no yeah no my mom and my grandma slept
in uh my grandma's bedroom
on the first floor together uh same bed
yeah
saint wait your mom and your grandmother
slept in the same bag same bet
just like they were just like check
blazers um
so they slept in the same bed then my
great grandmother and my aunt
lived in separate rooms upstairs i slept
in the basement downstairs
and then uh there was a man in our
living room who i just my whole family
would joke around and call him the
tenant
that's what i thought he was you know i
thought he was a renter and then i had a
friend come over in first grade first
time i ever had somebody over
and you know like when you have somebody
over and you're like that kid went home
like what yes
yes he's like yo mom no more of the
devitos okay wait hold on hold on
they're all wearing face shields
from the future
2020 you watch it's coming wait a minute
when you say
in the living room was it set up like a
living room or was it made to look like
a bedroom no no it was very much
just uh ordinary living room and they he
just slept on the floor
there was just a guy who slept on the
floor like a pill like did he have like
a sleeping bag
or anything or there was he might have
had a pillow and it was just
i didn't even think he had his own pill
i think it was a pillow like a throat
pillow from the
house oh man that's a tough one so there
was him in the living room
and then uh there's that moment where
you're like oh i got you know
you don't see any other families all
your life this is your normal
pretty much from when you became
self-aware when from when i gained
consciousness
this is my life and then friend comes
over first grade
looks around gets to the living room
he's like who's the man in your living
room
i was like that's our tenant and he was
uh then later that night i was like he
was like what's a tenant i was like i
don't really he's the guy who's on the
couch yeah
that's what a [ __ ] job so i've been
told so then i asked my mom about it
that night and she goes i never thought
we would have to tell you this he's
never thought you'd have to explain
the dude's sleeping on a throw pillow
man yeah i was trying to watch saturday
morning card
talk about short sighted you know that
also goes to show you how much of a
non-inquisitive kid
i was she was like you can throw
anything in this kid's face he won't say
anything because this kiss [ __ ] kid's
never gonna answer
dumbass i didn't think he'd ever figure
it in the [ __ ] yeah man he's happy with
life as it is
at all so who is he so i asked my mom
about that my mom goes that's your
grandfather
so what happened he cheated this is a
real thing he was an old guy
uh yeah he's a pretty old guy wait hold
on hold on oh please no
no no i'll tend to speed through so stop
along the way
i pictured a younger guy younger well
if you were sick say what's he like 50s
probably i mean you know when you're
real young you're like like a hundred
someone who's thirty is 105 years old so
uh yeah he was probably like fifty
sixties
okay i'd say somewhere in there um and
then yeah he
turned out to that he was my grandfather
um he cheated on my grandmother in the
50s she never forgave him
uh you know italian couple they didn't
get a divorce oh man
the house was in his name and she wasn't
gonna spend any more money
she said on him even to get a divorce so
she just banished him to the living room
exiled there all the food in the fridge
was marked not for john
he couldn't eat anything except the
waffles and uh
yeah that's just one that's a [ __ ]
grudge that's a bad airbnb
yeah me oh man i was scared out of my my
grandmother it's like
spot you know what i mean this went
beyond like threatening me with a wooden
spoon i was like she could
psychological warfare oh yeah that's
nuts holy [ __ ] well okay here's the
thing
that i'm curious about how would you not
even if he did cheat
and him and this there was a strange
relationship between him and his
grandmother
why they never introduced him to you as
this is your
the guy you've been living with [ __ ]
cold blood he's your grandfather no i
think he didn't
he didn't pick you up and hold you and
give you hugs and kisses well he did
he would try those things i thought he
was an affectionate rector
i really did oh my god and then yeah
turned out to be
that and i think my mom didn't want to
see uh an example of uh
like what marriage could turn into or
whatever and i think at some point they
felt like they didn't validate
he lived in the [ __ ] living room they
didn't know she was that's that's you're
even more [ __ ] up because of that
probably i there's got to be so many
things in this guy gets a hankering
every once in a while after a couple of
schlitzer's
jesus we're [ __ ] human beings what
did that do to you
uh i don't know there was i don't made
him become a welder yeah
that's when i first stopped join the
union yeah get some good pennies
how do you think it did yeah i went the
next day comics have said what's in my
first
union join the local yeah
it was like wait there's a pandemic
going on he's been just doing something
for years finally the world's caught up
um dude that's nuts
yeah i don't know i mean it probably did
things to me later on
in life when you're a kid there's just
so much that's just what it is did the
relationship
change after that not really because you
didn't say hey you're my
hey you're my [ __ ] grandfather why
didn't he tell you
well i think he was under the assumption
he was clearly afraid of the grandmother
i mean they got the guy sleeping on the
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] didn't
the house was in his name he's just like
a very proud guy what did he do for a
living he was a mechanic in the bronx
so he was getting up and going to work
every day coming home sleeping on the
hardwood floor oh yeah would he put
pajamas on
uh well yeah he wore these black
sweatpants he never wore a shirt i never
saw the man with a shirt on his whole
life
yeah that's crazy he wears black
sweatpants he'd watch animal shows and
he need waffles
that's all i knew of the man
he didn't know like he was under the
assumption he was my he was under the
assumption that i knew he was my
grandfather so he was just doing
grandfather stuff
just thought he didn't like him yeah
don't like this guy
yeah he's like my grandson's a little
cold yeah but i'm just kidding
we buying this good ice cream he goes uh
thank you renter
i'll put in a good word boy it lives by
a weird code but it's his name
you call him mr devito or something he
would he take you to the park
no never do anything like that i didn't
see him too much because he worked he
worked
long hours and then yet another you know
later we learned he had another family
on the side
so you know
yeah so
he was gone for most of the day i would
see him uh on weekends a little bit here
and there
and then i would see him when i left for
school and then
uh you know maybe like late at night but
you know he would probably get home like
10 or 11 o'clock something like that did
he sleep there every night
no he didn't so he was he had another
family and moved on
yes but he stayed there a couple nights
a week just to make sure legally that he
still lives in the house
probably yeah he was there probably now
looking back he's probably there like
four or five you know four nights a week
but wait if he had another house
and had another family why didn't he
just sell the old house
or well because my whole family lived
there so i i think he would
be kicking out like four generations why
wouldn't he just [ __ ] bounce
nine women would be on the street if he
did that
and a kid with a face shield why
wouldn't he just [ __ ]
you know not go there yeah i mean you're
like you're also thinking this like
logic like who knows i mean he
decided to sleep on the floor he's
clearly not like processing the [ __ ]
yeah options to some degree he's like
well he still looked at it as like his
house and his family so he wanted to be
around put time in
and [ __ ] yeah be semi-present or
whatever because my mom
my mom and my uh youngest aunt who lived
in was that their dad
yes exactly so this is their dad yeah so
he's like in the house with his kids
you never heard your aunt or your mother
call this guy dad
no no no he was john they would they i
mean they were funny so they would just
call him the tenant and i just thought
that's who he was
and then uh them just hearing that they
were like ah man these kids are 60s a
tenant we'll never have to tell them
this
weird thing i'm [ __ ] blown away
that's bananas yeah yeah that might be
the one
i mean we've had some wild [ __ ]
stories but that's that's
that's up there oh my my family they're
great kind and loving people they're out
to lunch
i mean this is just this is just left
field with a hockey stick oh yeah
they don't even know it's a broom they
think it's a hockey stick it's not a
real one
so no brothers and sisters no brothers
and sisters what was your room
my room i slept in a very just uh a very
unpolished
damn basement basement kids yeah can go
either way it can either be really cool
and tricked out or you're really like in
the cellar
it looked like yes you ever see those
crawl spaces
white footages of like uh like a steel
factory in pittsburgh very much look
like
kind of blair witchy yes very blair
witchy i was petrified of the dark it
was just a blast furnace
water surging through pipes at odd hours
and then
just an already scared boy just under
the covers freaked out
are you the penguin what the [ __ ] yeah
that's nuts i do have an affinity for
fish
wow a blast i feel like a nice mackerel
a nice
macro right out of the ocean a
dehumidifier scares a little kid a
[ __ ] blast
dude i was just i was like i was just at
my parents basement
getting all this [ __ ] and i was legit i
took one look into that crawl space and
hit the [ __ ] bricks
i ran up the stairs [ __ ] 34 year old
baldy man oh yeah i am so glad you said
that
i would run up the stairs i got this in
my head that like uh
the dark could get you if you didn't run
faster you got a stick and move coming
out of the basement
so fast from my bed to get cereal i
would ah man it was
like lightning quick up those stairs and
if i like fell or tripped
it was like a guy in vietnam like i just
kept going go without me
save yourself hey tenant save yourself
the darkness got me oh i thought the
darkness could get me
oh yeah i do i legitimately
no no i'd leave them every every time i
would a stomach ache would hit every
time at two in the morning
really i'd leave every sleeper he's like
hey timmy can you turn the blast furnace
up a little bit
yeah trying to feel at home does anyone
have night terrors in your family i'd
like to get a good night's sleep
i figured you'd want to do sleepovers uh
yeah
well i liked when they slept over but if
i slept over at somebody else's house
you know i would freak out
because i was i was petrified of the
dark so once that
you know the movie ended and and i
always like i couldn't sleep so then
everyone was sound asleep and it was
just
me and my old friend the blackness buddy
that was steve
laying there looking up at the ceiling
like how the [ __ ] do i get out of this
situation
is it too late to call dad what are we
doing
oh i i didn't i i was so afraid i would
march into uh
parents bedrooms of friends just knock
on the door and go oh yeah
those bagel bites didn't sit right you
gotta get me out of here call my mom and
then she'll pick me up
oh like an old jewish account
yeah i go while i'm at it let me look at
your books
you got your receipts on you mrs
stevenson what was in that pot room
i need an alka-seltzer in a cab quick
kevin let me ask you this
you're you're first second grade to get
the big invite over to your your good
friend anthony devito's house for a nice
sleepover happy to have you
have a nice bring your own well done
yeah you have a nice time and it's time
to go to bed
and he puts me in the basement
to [ __ ] buffalo bill's place it puts
the jammies on
yeah it puts the jammies what's this bar
of soap for
don't worry about a young kevin just
hold on yourself
see you hanging in there before you got
denise something dude i mean
get to the bottom of the stairs did you
have a friend sleep down there with you
yeah was it
i got a couple big
was the floor carpeted or was it like oh
no cold concrete
i mean you'd get arthritis if you were
down there for too long
oh probably cracked and [ __ ] [ __ ] not
even
just poorly painted attack mold
everywhere cinderblock walls
one that's like an insane asylum oh it
very much was it's wild that i'm
somewhat adjusted as i am
this was pretty pandemic folks we've had
this
we've had this one i'm telling you guys
there's nothing coming to the states
from china
man dude all right hold on now i want to
hear about this room
i'm amazed at how normal you are yeah at
this point and guys
we're not even out of [ __ ] second
grade yet oh it's sure
we're not going to take a minute to
appreciate that this kid's not even
middle school
yeah honestly we're not even at the
whopper
um yeah more about the basement uh yeah
it was very very
very scary i don't know i just don't
know what you want for me man i don't
like that place i don't like going back
there kevin
is the house still there uh no they tore
it down the uh yeah
jesus christ bishop came in
and burn it yeah yeah no a pope from
rome came
uh there's all kinds of chanting and
they seemed to have exercised whatever
was
oh yeah the priest that exercised that
place definitely smokes
yeah he wrote an autobiography
of anthony devito's basement yeah it was
uh i never put it it was like one of
those things because you know that
growing up when you're a kid you just
take everything at face value
and then someone comes over for the
first time or you go to someone else's
house
and then you're like oh things are not
what they say well that's that's kind of
what this whole show
is we found out it's like oh yeah not
it's weird to [ __ ] do you know
to have a tenant you know totally yeah
yeah that one's is really weird for sure
but
yeah that um i've gotten some other like
i guess it's kind
not that it's like very common in
italian families but like other
uh italian people have been like hey i
kind of had the same thing
really so it does seem to be like yeah
this like weird catholicism
it's like power struggle catholicism i
guess if
if he didn't cheat it would have been
less weird and it would have seemed
right so it's a very thin line
right but with the right the
conservative italians it's either going
to go see they're going to be great
[ __ ]
gravy on sunday hey everybody's here or
it's [ __ ] blast furnace
yeah spitting on the floor
yeah grandmother sounds like she put a
[ __ ] curse on somebody
oh she's a piece of work man but you put
your picture in the freezer
yeah no she could uh she could mess you
up uh psychologically that was her move
how was the cooking though good cook
good cook not i not did they feed you
oh yeah they took you carry on oh
they're were they affectionately
your grandmother are affectionately so
affectionate my my mom and my grandma i
mean italian mothers are they're this
notorious
but i don't [ __ ] know what this squad
chase very true but no no wildly
affectionate
very much fell in line of the italian
stereotype there and probably exceeded
it a little bit so they took good care
of it
very good okay yes no cook every night
my grandma not
people would always say like your
grandma's meatballs it's like yeah she
put peas in everything for some reason
she's like her cooking was fine but
really a little bit
huh interesting i kind of like that a
little bit
like the crazy yeah no she yeah you love
vicky
but yeah then uh you know then yeah the
whopper is here we go
my i didn't know uh i didn't find out my
mom had told me my whole life that my
dad had died in a car accident
and then when i got to high school i
found out that my dad
uh was a maid man in uh organized crime
fan
so holy and [ __ ] yeah they found i mean
she wasn't they you know
and he was still they found him in a car
uh oh they found
oh he had passed when you were a kid he
died when before
uh i was probably like a couple months
old or whatever
that's when he actually so when he
actually died there was an accident die
hard yes technically not a total lie uh
you know she didn't crash into another
car yeah yeah
she wanted the [ __ ] out of you yeah you
know how accidents go yeah they
accidentally fall under the trunk
accidentally they did yeah but you never
met him i never met him uh
this all happened when i was um an
infant
or like me a couple months old like
really really early on
and my mom she just she didn't want me
she wanted me to know uh and she also
she didn't want anyone to look at me
differently that was her show
she was like you know growing up
i grew up it was kind of um it was not
an affluent suburb but it was like
not everybody came from like strange
italian family like we had a lot going
on so to add one more
thing on i think she was like was it you
don't need that in your life just try to
keep it a little more normal yeah yeah
she wanted to give me a real puncher's
chance it was an affluent area but you
you you guys wasn't like a single family
home right we lived in a state we
weren't
part of the affluence we were you know
struggling to make it as a family
by no means like were we like super poor
we were lower middle class
but like that's where our situation was
at in comparison to everybody else in
town
i got you doing pretty wouldn't even
make it worse yes exactly
um so yeah i didn't find how did you
find out yeah who told you
uh i what happened was it was sort of
another uh kind of just like
happenstance
accident situation where i was playing
basketball in high school at a local
park
and there was a guy there on the other
team who looked
a lot like me just and he i never seen
him before and then
everyone just called me devito on the
court and then after the game he was
like your last name is devito and i was
like yeah he was like i'm your cousin
from your father's side and i was like i
was excited because i didn't i didn't
know
really anybody from my father's side i'm
an only child so
to kind of have someone like close to my
age like a brother yeah there's also
another guy like it's all women who
raised me so i was
i was jacked i went home to tell my mom
and my mom
uh she was like i need you to sit down
for this
and then she was like your father didn't
die in a car accident
he was a made man in a crime family so
ah but when she told me she was
like my mom is like i was saying like
she's very
like overly kind like so and when you're
only child
your mother is everything you know so
it's like i never wanted to see her have
any pain whatsoever
so she when she was telling me she had
water in her eyes so i was like
i didn't really pry any further because
like i could see how hard it was for her
to even tell me that
so i just kind of accepted it and then
just kind of moved on
and then later on um when we got a
computer i started to kind of look more
into him and found out more and things
like that
man you're a good [ __ ] dude i'm
telling you that right now i'm all right
man
you know what now i see the whole
picture the whole picture is your wife
would have been your life would have
been
completely different if your father was
alive you would have been
the son of a [ __ ] made guy in a crime
fight yeah it would have you know it
would have been the sopranos
basically but instead that happened he
gets he he gets killed
yeah so then it went the other way yeah
exactly it goes the other way
and so that their whole thing was
protecting you totally
yeah crazy what did your what did they
say about your
fat like when you were like hey did dad
have any brothers or sisters like
growing up
what was the lie about your dad's family
or something you know
and why did they want you to get
involved with them my dad said they're
criminals
well just his dad one cousin wasn't no
they they
just wanted they i mean you know that's
their
son and i'm their grandson not
necessarily like they want to recruit me
into the family
you know that's what i'm saying like
didn't your father where was your
father's parents
um they well there was uh
my family or my mom in particular just
wanted them solely out of the picture so
that became like a legal issue
wow just because um so they did want to
see you and have they did
yes that we and we ended up having some
kind of a relationship
it wasn't after meeting your cousin um
no or
even before prior but i didn't know and
it was just like hey this is your dad's
mother this is your grandmother
on this side and then i think we would
probably see her like once every couple
months
you know nice lady just ate eggs at a
diner kind of thing
really unassuming and then later on in
life when i found that out it was really
seeing how scared my mom was that i
never
like i never wanted to reach out you
know like they they could be fine people
they're probably great people in
some ways yeah it was more than that i
didn't want it so that was it you left
yeah
and she and god she was a good mom you
know what i mean like she wasn't a good
mom i might have been like all right
push back a little bit right yeah like
she never asked for anything and she
gave me a lot so it's like
if for her just to ask of this one thing
it seemed like very
easy in a way for me to just uh fulfill
that wish
now was your was your father the only
one involved in organized crime in his
family or was
his father also involved they yeah they
would their family
was uh it was a family of uh yeah
yeah yes he's like all right yeah just
uh moving on
well yeah yeah you keep your mouth shut
that's worse than the first two that was
my dad's final meal
he was bringing jello shots home for me
and my mom
they got him kippy anthony
that's insane yeah i mean i knew when i
like also too when you started working
on you the one man show right like you
know before the pandemic
it started make like the story they're
like you gotta hear this [ __ ]
you gotta hear the story devito's story
is crazy yeah and for me it was like um
i i always i never talked about it just
because my mom told me
not to you know um and then eventually i
mean you guys know doing comedy it's
like
you burn through where you're from what
do you do you know what i mean
get to the stake baby
oh man i'm sorry i see toby every time i
laugh it's such a
crazy cackle he keeps it just
all right cool but um yeah kind of that
and then also you know what it is with
comedy it's like uh
like truth is currency yeah so it's like
to have something that you can't be
honest about
um was really hard on stage and off
stage
so uh you know cause you'd be talking to
people and they would reveal things
about themselves and then they would be
like yeah what about you and i'd be like
yeah i never met the man love jello
but i mean that's really in a credit to
your character and that's really going
to credit to
when you know art comes out in an
organic natural way
other [ __ ] bozos that would have been
the first thing out of their [ __ ]
mouth
but you you know what i mean right
you're a good person and you didn't want
to share
that's what that's what's probably
making the show so powerful
yeah what i mean i i hope so i mean
thank you i was very nice to you um
and but uh yeah it's also a thing too
where like i wanted to do this story
justice you know when you first start
out like you don't know
i don't even know that i know how right
now to be like necessarily like funny
and sincere and all those things when we
first started out like i don't even know
how to just be funny
you would have been doing it like my dad
you would have been doing it like
baseball bat
for me it was like i have to do this has
to be
um you wanted to wait to become the
artist that you wanted yeah
to tell the story and do it just yeah
god damn justice for me
yeah i wanted to be this artist and i
just looked through at the mask
the face shield it's so fun we're having
this like
like yeah that's when i realized my true
art was in his
[ __ ] he's wearing a facial that says
face shield i mean
what are we doing
i told you that i felt the microphone
clipped the plastic of this and i was
just laughing in my head
but um so funny yeah and also too for
like his family you know what i mean
because it's like yeah you write these
people off and i think the sopranos did
a good job of rounding out
kind of who these people are as humans
rather than just cartoons so it's like
when i told this story or i'm in the
midst of telling this story like i
wanted to honor him to them
as well you know what i mean it's like
his family yeah cause it's like look
you know you're not just you're a
product of circumstances to
a big degree you're not just like a born
however you're born
and it's also it's like there's shades
of him that aren't just like what i
could read about in the paper
so for me too it's like i wanted to
investigate that so i could
paint a whole picture for myself of
course yeah because it's like you know
you because he's someone where it's like
yeah i could read about like
you know i found out however i found out
by reading an article about him and in
that you know that's just like
they're just relaying information but
like to my mom that's her husband and to
me that's my father so for me it's like
yeah i i need to kind of carve out a
full thing otherwise it's like hard to
reconcile with just what you
see in print of course yeah yeah i'm
going to ask you a question now oh yeah
just because of the piece of [ __ ] that i
know i am i know you're the opposite
you're a great guy
when you read that article i know if it
was me
was there any percentage of you for a
second where you were like
that's pretty [ __ ] cool of course
okay yeah because it's so romanticized
in american culture it's like what like
dude there's like polish guys who are
like [ __ ] right did you start
dressing my
second cousin's italian you started
dressing differently
yeah yeah [ __ ] wing tips and a suit
to school how you doing good to see you
boom
boom boom [ __ ] breaking off the gym
teacher yeah
i got a bad ankle today jimmy yeah i
don't want to do the ropes
this is for you make sure it's a b-plus
climb up there you're looking at my
balls
that's so funny i don't even ask for an
a yeah it's a b-plus all right let's not
get nobody's showing off i don't want to
draw attention i don't what are you
looking over here all of a sudden this
gets smart
that's what you got to do you can't let
the heat on you right away you got a
[ __ ]
middle of the pack that's too funny
there was a yeah there is that party
where you know like you're like yeah i
don't know man i'm i'm
i'm a guy at 18. you know what i mean
who's just like yes this is cool
but then also but then it just i would
always just see that
vision of my mom and that was the part
where i was like i can't think it's that
cool because
there's clearly a lot of pain associated
with sure so it was like there was that
kind of like there's no romanticizing
for her
yes exactly there's a there's a perfect
way to put it is
this thing is it still an ongoing thing
as far as like how gentle you have to be
as far as names and all that kind of
stuff is it still
um i don't i don't even know i i treat
it that way
yeah it just goes to black for no reason
but ernie starts playing last thing you
see is a plate of onion rings hit the
table
shout out to sopranos oh man uh yeah no
i
treat it that way um in case
but more so because if um his side of
the family ever heard it i wouldn't want
them to be like
hey we're we're sort of misrepresented
here we're disrespecting of course
okay um so yeah and also too i just
think
like treating something that way you're
gonna get more depth out of it than
just um just kind of uh going the easy
route like of course
what you were saying yeah are you still
do you have a relationship with them at
this point in your life not really i
mean we
uh maybe we're like we're friends on
social media but that's the extent of it
and
not that i'm opposed you know what i
mean um it's just uh
what it is for right now yeah wow i i i
must have you k
i thought i must have been confused with
somebody else i thought your mom was
dating a blind guy
that's that was my grandmother that was
your grandmother your grandmother was
dating like a
you had the bit about it yes the old
black blind guy yeah my grandma
jesus christ she met yeah she met
[ __ ] i know what do you mean what
we're playing we're shooting hoops
and we had two tenants you know i don't
want to brag
i don't want to brag but and a
grandfather
when did when did the when did the blind
black guy move in that
he never moved in she uh towards the end
of her life
she met him in a nursing home where she
went into the nursing home and then
my grandmother you know she's an italian
woman from jersey like this is a
this is a racist woman
that's yeah so put it delicately um it's
not split linguistics
let's say she's from the old country
yeah
so she meets this um she's like horrible
she's uh
depressed in the nursing home first
couple months meets this
uh blind black guy with one leg who's
25 years younger than her falls in love
with him and uh
wanted to marry him they never did but
like you know we looked into it we
couldn't figure it out because he uh his
brother was
his legal guardian and his brother met
my grandmother and said you can't marry
this woman
really which i always think is great um
well she's 25 years older
yeah how old was she at the time she was
uh uh like 93
92 to 95 is when she was in the nursing
home wait the years or the
eight i love how both families were like
we can't be doing this like you yeah
we're like crazy very you're not this is
irresponsible you all
are not wrong my mom would try to like
say like why would be like why do you
think it's wrong and she's like it just
didn't
there's an age difference just trying to
squeeze that little nugget of like
out just say it oh wow but yeah no they
yeah this was like this unlikely
relationship yeah they fell in love
wanted to get mad that's like a bad
sitcom
yeah it kind of yeah or a great one yeah
well i'm just saying like it's
an over-the-top cheesy sitcom yeah what
can we do let's get the old
racist italian and the yo you know the
younger cool black guy with that you're
100
you know how many network meetings they
just went you got a multi-cam on your
hands
and every time i sat down to write it i
went i'm writing the biggest piece of
garbage
like exactly what you're saying no
single cam good acting little dramatic
beginning
yeah i i like it foley is the lead
character
maybe you have a guy host a podcast i
started a patreon
good dude underrated i'll play the
basement
you're the you're the blast
it's like avenue q now did they did they
move in together in the nursing home or
anything
no they uh they didn't move in together
separate rooms uh
they wanted they're waiting for marriage
yeah old school
saving themselves i like it yeah that
was my mom's i've done a bit about but
that is that was my mom's fears that
they wanted to get married for sexual
reasons
oh so they could move it's like let them
you know yeah of course
i assume nursing homes everybody's
[ __ ] oh it is they're rampant
gonorrhea is like a rampant problem yeah
yeah stds and
they let it fly good for them nobody
dumping clips mainly they don't have the
dexterity for condoms
manipulate a fork there's no chance a
little meatloaf some jeopardy and a
little [ __ ]
little butt a little bit of and so she
was in love with him and happy with him
until she died in the nursing home yes
yeah and is she still there he is not he
passed actually a couple months before
her
and then uh then she went yeah wow yeah
and where's your mom now my mom is in
north jersey in an apartment
um by herself by herself no no she's
she's just by herself where's where's
the aunt
uh i do a lot of them pass and then it's
just one aunt who lives in delaware
no the aunt that lived with you yes she
passed the young one
yes unfortunately yeah natural causes
natural yeah
yeah i know you gotta ask talking about
i like how you didn't pick up on that
he's like a lot of them
like what you were living with i'm like
idiot that's him saying she passed yeah
no my family
uh
you're totally fine man um yeah um we're
yeah
they're just like uh my mom's side at
least a history of cancer in the family
so
a lot of them just got it and uh that's
yeah what happened
but um but yeah i mean like you know
growing up it was a very large
big uh italian family full of women it
was a lot of fun
okay high school was somewhat normal
like once you found this out
processed it yeah pretty pretty normal
um and also it was like sports to play
sports yeah i played basketball
soccer you know um yeah it was kind of a
thing too where like
my within my family there were so many
lies going on
with like my so it was like finding that
out i was like why not throw in them
yeah whatever yes at this point um it
wasn't until
reading reading the graphicness of uh
how he died that's when i was like oh
this is
this is i felt the impact of like oh
this is going to mean more
faster than the yeah everything else
yeah damn wow but yeah
um but it is like you know i don't know
the the good fortune of them doing
comedy and having
all of like just having this wealth of
material sort of
at my fingertips that's the one thing
that's like that's the pressure that i
feel because there's so much
to you know impossible to the story i
feel responsible to destroy this
[ __ ] good comic right there thanks a
lot dad
my [ __ ] dad fix his air conditioner i
can't even [ __ ] do something cool
that i can't do a one-man show
there he was you know this thing
wouldn't even get into the outlet
yeah right but there's still time he
there he didn't even have his crescent
he's like two
sugars all right let's play a little bit
of
hey jesus
i feel like we should muffle your voice
that's what the shield's for
yeah i've never had a lunch
uh let yeah let's dip into a little are
you garbage now i'm gonna ask you this
and we're gonna kind of look for sure
let's take it from high school on
because that's what i was kind of
getting that
uh do do you think you're garbage i
don't disrespect no no no
no
smashes my head no no not at all did you
dabble in high school at all a little
racketeering any book making anything
like that did you keep a book or
anything uh well
i kept stats for the football team so
maybe i am not
right actually it wasn't like a book i
was fixing the game
yeah sure i fudged some tackles who
didn't back then that's what we were
doing
okay yeah i think so man i mean
definitely
like uh myself sure like i live in
sweatpants i don't i shower every four
days absolutely
okay nice you know i look like a pile of
wet leaves come to life
well you kept your self-esteem up that's
good to see that
um were you a good student in high
school uh
i was okay i had to really apply myself
i knew that
where i wasn't very i never was not very
very smart it's very dumb i'm like
someone who just got recently struck by
lightning
i'm just like a little off you know i i
would say that's the best way like
michael
yeah kind of like michael that's where
my brain is
a real face-off yeah real john stephen
did you go to college i went to college
i went to university of miami
whoa okay out of state pretty good
school to get in proper or like some
satellite campaign no no i know what you
mean
in kansas
but uh no yeah i went there i had a ton
of financial aid
uh given to me um and show what you call
it
that's financial aid right um so yeah i
went there i went there i actually
studied uh i have a bachelor's degree in
architecture i
studied architecture that's pretty good
you gotta be good with math and
i am not no no what'd you get on your
sats yeah so i was getting oh i got a
1060. it was low that's all right
you break a thousand you're i mean yeah
yeah
big man didn't do so hot it's all right
it's a ridiculous way
to measure intelligence you know i
wouldn't feel bad for yourself there
fully it sounds like a 10-60 i got a lot
of the reasons
you know you come to the party sounds
like would you say something sounds like
a 1060 saying
that it's a bad way to test you know
yeah
hey we're all good we're all the same
thing right in that beady part of the
bell curve yeah
no way put his face shield on
i need to protect myself from the dumb
yeah um
okay so yeah no i wrote a good essay so
i think that's what really got me in did
you talk about
your dad oh i talked about my aunts
dying and things like that and i think
uh
i was always pretty decent writing um so
i think that's what really did it and
then
architecture no i was terrible with math
it's such a blessing that i'm not an
architect people will be dead
um i'm horrible with logistics and math
i was good with like uh
because a lot of it in college
especially is like uh conceptual
yeah like it's like incredible yeah so i
could do that very well i could make
connections okay i could design
good but like um uh everything else like
the actual like structural integrity
there's i have nightmares about
buildings in fort lee that i worked on
oh absolutely what made you want to be
an architect uh well this was the
basement
uh yeah i wanted to design a bedroom
people
uh no it was when i was 16 my youngest
aunt and
she was on her deathbed from cancer she
asked me what i was going to do to make
the family proud
i i had just watched three men and a
baby the night before i remember tom
selleck was an architect
i'm gonna knock some broad up and live
with my boys
they look like fun man what do you think
i'm gonna do yeah i don't know hang out
with steve gutenberg for an hour and a
half
um so i just i had that in my head in a
pinch i just said it and then
she lived and my family never forgot and
so that's what happened
dude you guys are [ __ ] sick you
promised on a deathbed
you were going to be an astronaut not
getting that rocket he
come on i'm scared i don't know
she'll put a curse on you from heaven
get in there you're gonna see me looking
up at you from the moon
you're looking back down don't you
[ __ ] embarrass me
dude that's like [ __ ] vendetta that's
right i'm gonna become a [ __ ]
architect
how italian are we talking sicilian half
sicilian we're talking murdered in a
trunk
what
did your mother make a sauce shut up the
guy's connecting he's a big man
how italian it's like asking a
leprechaun you ever been to ireland
you're gonna get his [ __ ] cliff over
here shut up you guys are good boys
you're good boys you're good boys
your friend told me i'm going to have
you oh god oh this has to go
beyond the patreon or something i'm not
i'm too paranoid yeah we're in the woods
behind some rest stops
using a funny guy
this is going to be 500 000 on patreon
small bills non-sequential bills
i'm just saying man that's why
now i know what you're saying i mean
it's not even kind of like a baseball
player or something
an architect you know how hard it is to
be an architect very hard too hard
especially
yeah tell me
i had to take high school math when i
was in college
i was the only architect that went to
summer school it really you're not wrong
i had to take this night class everybody
in there was 45 years old
i've had to take those still this one
guy i've never had to take a night class
that's trash yeah they like they give
you sick breaks just quit yeah just give
it up
it's like we're gonna take five i swear
it's like an aaa meeting
yeah but they give you a book
because it was like every i was so
behind in math that i had to take this
night class on campus
everybody in there was [ __ ] every and
there was everybody in there was
divorced everyone there was old and then
i just remember the last day of the
class the teacher goes there was this
guy
he kind of slept through every class
head down like this was a real drunk nap
and um the teacher goes all right what
does everyone want to do he pops up and
just goes get drunk go to flanigan's and
then just
went right back to sleep and i was like
this is this is nuts
and now he's an architect
folks um he did the new addition to the
guggenheim
i'm not familiar with the university of
miami school of architecture is it an
accredited institution or
it is an accredited institution at the
time uh there was this group that was
running it called the new urbanists
uh who you guys see the truman show yeah
so that that's a real town in seaside
florida
so that was their whole model of thought
was like turning in
america into sort of spaces like that
sure they did the same thing with uh
section 8 housing in philadelphia where
they modeled after a holland design
company
yes to not make it you know the high
rises but to make them like little
almost town homes
yes so that's that the so the school at
the time and i didn't really know
anything i literally went there to not
disappoint my family i didn't know
anything about dark souls nuts
yeah everybody was there talk about like
catholic guilt dude
you're like the guy who knew too little
and asked nothing literally
that's going through it for sure i would
have been yeah i would have been fine in
my father's line of work
i tell you what to do this kid andy
don't ask no questions
there's been a guy on his floor for six
months he hasn't said a [ __ ] word
i know yes you'd be running things by
now
yeah you know um well you know there's
still time we'll see what happens
yeah that'd be a great ending to the
story
listen we got a big meeting all right i
got to keep a face shield don't know my
girlfriend
yeah meanwhile exactly i'm afraid of my
girlfriend who's this [ __ ] listen my
mom's gonna be upset if i show up
without no man's skull
lorenzo who's this guy who's this
[ __ ] guy
holy [ __ ] god so
fantastic you just went to miami yeah
i need to be an architect yes and and i
didn't
do any architecture after you graduated
college yeah i worked in an
office for uh like a year and a half uh
in north jersey
um just like family firm um it was like
the dad
his two sons and then his uh his wife
did the accounting and
uh it was it was horrible it was a
nightmare i mean i was i'm also
like i'm too shy i'm i have this like
great uh
combination of like being completely
incompetent but then too shy to ask any
questions
so i was just everything was wrong he
would just come over and he would just
be like
we're gonna get sued because like
architectural drawings are legal
documents yeah so yeah
it was it was a nightmare i was a
horrible employee he
was a verbally abusive man it was it was
brutal
you probably weren't used to that [ __ ]
what's that you weren't used to that
[ __ ] having a
[ __ ] busting your balls oh no not at
all you're one sleeping on the floor
like a dog
kick him when you walked out the door
move over you
johnny you better not be here when i get
back
he did like johnny quest you're not off
johnny quest was awesome that was good
man yeah and what about now now uh
now you're in a relationship yeah now
i'm in a relationship you have an
apartment
yeah architecture is long behind long
long you've been doing stand-up how many
years about 11 years now
processed everything to a degree you're
starting to talk about it
yeah well that was always the thing with
everything there was always a lot of
love behind it so it never
really it never it you know maybe messed
me up in certain ways but it never
it wasn't like so detrimental because it
was like yeah but they were always just
nice to me
you know so it was like it never really
was like this like brooding this
horrible thing like there's like aspects
where it's like oh that's probably
related to that but it's
they're they're flashes they're not just
like it's not driving the bus
exactly yeah yeah and you know what adds
to it a little bit makes it endearing a
little bit sadder a little bit
you know awesome too is that they're all
they're all gone now yes
the promises you made as an architect
that they're all they're
all done your grandmother your aunt yeah
mom your mom's still your mom i'm still
alive your mom still yeah okay and she
how does she feel about you being a
comic she loves it with it oh she loves
doesn't hold a grudge with you against
the architecture no once comedy started
they'll lied to me
he wrote some sold out special or
something like that well my mom told me
so many lies that it's like
she's got no grounds you know um uh no
she's so i mean the bar is so low
for me as long as i don't become a
criminal
yeah so though you don't end up in a
trunk
you're pretty good exactly so uh no she
she
loves me doing comedy and then
especially like when it um
when you know having some success at it
yeah she totally
didn't care about the architecture
anymore because she's like well okay
you've
you've made you've made more doing you
made more here than you would have
there and you're happy and sure you're
all the things that i work so hard for
you
to be that's great so that's fantastic
she got the payoff well said
yeah i thought i loved you before i love
you even more now
[ __ ] something else but unfortunately
this isn't all fun and gameplay
some are you garbage questions to see
how you're shaped up now you mentioned
the sweatpants
all right now listen the story's sad but
we're not the [ __ ] school board
university of miami
we're not giving you any passes all
right because let me tell you this i
don't care if you're
another guy you're sitting across from
him yeah
so any superstitions do i have to ask
ah no i don't think would you walk under
a ladder
yeah i don't care i don't care about i
don't care about that stuff that's
pretty good yeah
you never carry a lucky rabbit's foot no
i did carry
yeah now that you mention it 1995 was a
weird one
um no i i remember carrying i i went to
a strip club in miami
and uh one of the strippers hair uh i
fell in my wallet so i remember how i
had that in my wallet for a little bit
a piece of hair yeah what yeah well
that's the thing with you guys you know
you
you really you get a guest to open up
and then you go i can see anything on
here
and then you go one bridge too far and
you're like i think that's my title
are you garbage but uh uh yeah for what
reason just
wait it fell into the wallet yeah and
then you found it
later or you saw it no it just landed in
my wallet and i was like well i'm gonna
keep this because i want to remember her
okay a little token oh my god creep
balls
yeah look hearing it now it's a little
how did their hair come out
i had my scissors on me yeah of course
who doesn't go to a strip club without
their blade
excuse me
just how many lap dances did you get
you fell in love didn't you yeah of
course it was uh it was like one of the
first times i saw a naked woman oh
yeah okay especially with you i thought
this was like a couple of weeks ago oh
no
this is college
yeah no this is uh you know the first
time i got a lap dance i stole her shoes
still wear them was it once oh
was it one strand or a couple i i
it might have been a couple you know you
folded how long did you keep them
well as long as it one day it wasn't
there anymore and i went well i guess
that's over
our level i guess she's moved on to
other people
did you ever smell them no i never
smelled it dude
it wasn't it was it wasn't uh it was
more like when i would look at that i
would think of her and that was a nice
moment
it wasn't like i was like uh hey i need
to go into my uh a private room
and uh inhale her hair it wasn't
anything like that
it was a little token you took yeah it
was kind of like a serial killer
kind of you know i'd go in the shadows i
thought you were trying to sugarcoat nah
i was trying to draw him down and hit
him like a real good hoe trying to get
him to confess
it was quite a good cop bad guy quite a
hammer but uh no
i was um it never i never saw it as like
you know how like you read about serial
killers or psychopaths or whatever and
they really
no but you know how like they've really
they have such gumption and following
through on there it's a it's such an
obsession
it's a lot of work i wasn't i wasn't
putting in that much effort you know
what i mean
if i was if i was really toeing the line
and doing things and putting on kabuki
masks and things of that nature
i might have said i've got some things
going on here but uh it was more for me
i was like
i'm a horny innocent i know exactly what
this is okay yeah okay
all right oh man that's [ __ ] wild
uh i got one you currently have on
matching socks
let me check yeah these are good
matching guys
oh they look new unless you clean them
or they need to clean them no these are
new
uh julia got these for me for my
birthday uh i'll say
they'll be matching but more often than
not a sock i'll have a hole in it
sure yeah it's okay yeah the sweatpants
are nice you got a nice
clean shirt on thanks i'm doing my you
know i've been doing my best here
what's good he's got his going out pants
on have you uh yeah well i knew the
cameras would be rolling today
i've got hd cooking here 1080. have you
ever been to a circus
ah yes an actual proper circus yes i
remember we went to barman bailey when i
was really young and i hated it yeah me
too
yeah that's jeremy the circus that's
[ __ ] garbage
yeah really yes we never you know it
when you're a kid when you walk in yes
yeah like this is [ __ ] trash stinks
like peanuts and elephant [ __ ] yeah
everybody's got glow sticks you're like
what is this this isn't an airport in
the 50s
what are we doing yeah you see that
something just seems wrong
you know the animals aren't happy you
know the clowns are all [ __ ] weirdos
and
creeps yes yeah i didn't like that [ __ ]
at all i don't care how much cotton
candy you got
get me the [ __ ] out of here well said
yeah close those things down
that i hope that's first order those are
those probably aren't too far away
um have you ever been to a pawn shop uh
i i feel like i have but it doesn't
have you ever pawned anything no no i've
never pawned anything
no i feel like i've been in a pawn shop
but there's no i don't know if i i think
i was just there out of curiosity i
don't think i was there
for business you weren't shopping yeah i
was just like hey i'll peek in yeah i
want to know what's going on in these
things i've heard about them for you
weren't trying to you weren't trying to
get a gun or something no
no no yeah i i wouldn't i
need some nickel on it how much for
nicole's hair
you need to leave i'm going to give him
a human hair i'm gonna have to bring in
my hair guys take a look at this
and i got a guy knows all about special
hair
hi i'm anthony i own a hair stripper
and today i'm here to
ah my girlfriend says this is garbage uh
i'll open it to both of you fine
gentlemen
um at night do you ever take your socks
off
with your feet and leave them in the bed
overnight oh yes
yeah i'm big on that i love slipping
them socks using the big toe
oh hook and pull there's nothing better
all right
so and you get a reminder of the power
of the toe
yeah you forget what these wigglies can
do from a day-to-day basis
once that big toe slides that sock off
start looking yeah you go you got
you got something down there there's a
there's a big difference between between
big toe witch sock and big toe no sock
it's like condom no condom you know what
i mean absolutely
you know all due respect she seems like
a nice girl but she's dead wrong here
okay
ah you you're sleeping you're relaxing
the whole point of this thing
is to be in a complete state of
relaxation
and now you're leaving the bed this this
warm cocoon
to throw socks on the floor no now's the
time to treat yourself like a hotel room
yeah and just
just enjoy yes well my thing is my socks
don't make it to bed
that's how i was going to ask too what
what do you sleep in a face shield
well i do you got to be careful face
shield condom jock strap
those are my rules with a cup
um what uh sweatpants and then uh
underwear underwear yes underwear yeah
yeah i'll do underwear and then if i get
too hot i'll take the sweatpants off
i like the taking the clothes off in the
bed more than i do
before because then it's a whole
temperature change sure you know it's
like uh going to a different climate
right away there's something about a
little vacation yeah it feels travel
yeah you know yeah i get it it's like
the fall first fall day
nice and cool hey babe i'm gonna head to
yeah bermuda so i like that part of it
t-shirt
t-shirt yes yeah t-shirt if i get too
hot obviously take it off
and then uh and then you guys doing a
lot of moving and shaking right
now no it's a whole it's like a britney
spears concert yeah
you know um and then you know upon
request obviously if uh
the girlfriend wants to shirt off i'll
do that i don't think she likes that for
some reason
unless sex unless you know we're having
sex then she likes
obviously but uh in just normal times
she's more a fan of the shirt on i think
she likes a smoother surface
rather than my chest i know she's got a
hairy chest yeah i got it
okay all right interesting i uh
i got a couple from patreon yeah man
this is from ian shout out to ian who
joined the patreon if you join the
patreon we'll read your questions
um that's what we're doing because we
love you because we love you and we just
get so many from everybody we get
thousands it's like we're never gonna
get to them all so
you know when you join we'll answer one
of your questions this is from ian
this did your family frequent yard sales
on the weekends
um yes really yeah my aunt midge was a
big
yard she was amazing you got a midge you
got a niche wait what was your real name
margaret
okay yeah it's pretty close that's in
the wheelhouse we're big on ants that
had names that weren't her name
oh i had an aunt soupy uh-huh oh yeah
it's super
super great quinny it's soupy yeah
funny soupy salad she did an impression
i don't even know the story but it was
aunt soupy my mom yo soup
my household we're talking about that
sounds so crazy but you know how many
times i've heard yeah where's supe
i love it the amount of times i've heard
soupy sales mentioned in my house
yeah dave my mom loves to tell me about
you know the scam that super sales ran
when he was a game show host
he did this thing he kicked off the air
force oh did he really i didn't yeah
he said kids go into your mother's place
oh and
send me a dollar and then they all like
millions of people send them money
yeah yeah forgot about it this cartoon
thief got a bunch of children
to send him money and envelopes and
gotten a ton of trouble
where are you in trouble for that uh i
guess uh soliciting yeah i don't know
the law
but uh it seems like something he's an
architect not a lawyer yeah
yeah folks get an envelope send a dollar
send an ru garbage just go to patreon i
send five of them how about that
the reason the studio is called aunt
tooties is because brian our buddy brian
sixx has a aunt hoodie
oh yeah he's great she sounds like she's
from good fellas
yeah he's amazing yeah midge was midge
was great she was uh
she was by far our she was the only
person in our family
who did have money um uh but she shopped
at a garage sales i don't we never i
never could put it together as to why
she would take you with her um yeah i
went a couple times with her it was so
boring
yeah you know because you always think
they're like i'm gonna get something
thanks absolutely it's like it's an arm
of a gi joe yeah
half his face melted off yeah and then
she's like look at this old lamp
and i'm like i just want this day to
happen this is horrible how much further
honey he said something about milkshakes
after this
i'll give you a nickel for it uh yeah uh
this is from kayla have you ever used a
bluetooth speaker or headphones in your
car because your stereo was broken
oh oh man that i've used uh
i didn't have a bluetooth but i remember
like uh the i
i have just definite memory of like ipod
wired headphones in yeah driving yeah i
still do because my car now just has a
cd player
not a dragon and uh when we go on trips
we'll bust out like the bose
and put it on the dashboard oh yeah yeah
we're trash man what do you want from me
what am i gonna listen to the [ __ ]
radio like a jerk who has cds
i gotta get into the phillies yeah
exactly
checking the weather and traffic on the
eights what are you doing my buddies
give me some [ __ ] pandora or
something yeah my buddy's dad had
his radio was broke in his car and all
through high school he just had a boom
box in there
that was like right it was in the center
in the front he had like those
those bench seats yeah and it was in the
front and that's great had bungee cords
around it the worst part about it
was when the bluetooth when the
bluetooth speaker dies
it's like just gets real quiet
yeah just me and my wife so
we still love each other right yeah yeah
geez louise this is a big one that we've
talked about before this is from uh this
is from nick
uh on patreon uh do you put the twist
tie back on the bread when you're done
or do you like to twist and fold
you're kind of crazy pure psychopath
i don't know what you're doing i'd love
to climb in there and find out
and i'm in there um i no i i twist it
you i i twist i don't think i
i think i do probably a bit of both i
don't because some people will twist
twist twist twist and then it's like
well the next time you want bread it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work and then
i go i'm just not gonna have bread then
yeah
so i i do if i probably do two twists
and then i do a full a tuck
yeah i do a talk really yeah i think
that's the gentleman's way
i believe it's called we're not a
[ __ ] animal over here where do you
keep the bread
keep the bread uh in we have a pantry
next to the fridge
julia has just put the bread in the
fridge which has been confusing
um but uh lasts longer yeah i think
she's trying to get it to last longer
but then it's like well now i have to
heat up the bread in the microwave when
i want a sandwich
not ideal but you know god bless her
what kind of bread you're rolling with
at the house you're just doing rye
you're doing white what are you doing i
like a white i don't i don't like to
skimp
on bread i don't i mean wheat's fine but
uh some it just gets too hard and it's
too much
i i like uh i like a white more than
like a wonder a strowman's what are you
doing
uh do you have a brand you go to or just
what is that nature's grain
or something okay yeah i got you white
nature's grain
growing up we had wonderful that was for
sure uh but uh yeah
you know it's got like a bale of wheat
on it i feel like it's like healthier
makes a country white oh sara lee i've
had that that's very very
little dusting of flour on top of it
excellent yes
[ __ ] it's like eating rubber just
moist just perfect
in a good way good rubber yeah hear that
sara lee i didn't want to offend you
good what uh
what's the sandwich usually ah sandwich
i like a
uh so yeah you got the white bread and
then i got like a honey maple turkey
and then i've got uh swiss and then
swiss
yeah i like swiss but me too yeah holy
days
not a lot of people are buying swiss
well it's a powerful cheese for a
powerful man yes
i love swiss and then uh i'll do um i
forget who
who makes this it's kind of like a it's
like a rendition of a big mac sauce you
know eventually everyone kind of came
out it's like a mayonnaise ketchup
orangey like okay thousand island
dressing things put it together
so i'll usually i'll fry that um with
you know a little bit of olive oil maybe
a little bit of butter oh you're making
that hot
yeah i make it hot i like it i like if
if i can right
if i've got the time i'll do that that's
my go-to damn um
but uh yeah interesting that's a pretty
classy sandwich yeah and then if i have
chips available i'll i'll throw some uh
oh i love a pickle i've got one good god
knows you know they don't stay long
though
i if i got pickles they're out the door
you come a long way from the blast
furnace
honey swiss cheese squish cheese is
great that's
swiss cheese there's actually two swiss
cheeses there's cold swiss cheese and
there's [ __ ] melted swiss cheese yeah
because there is nothing
they're just two whole different things
and they're both [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] fantastic i'll take a
french onion
any day of the [ __ ] water yeah
absolutely right you can't put any other
cheese in that situation and make that
soup possible no no
no it's [ __ ] banging killer all right
so that's we know about that a little
bit well i mean the swiss cheese ain't
pulling them out
you know i don't know i think he served
his time
you know he served his time in the
[ __ ] basement and in the dark
you know i'm saying from even kyle with
the stripper's hair you're not coming
back
that's [ __ ] next level wire i forgot
about that
it wasn't flat i don't dude he can
[ __ ] shove swish cheese up his
[ __ ] it ain't [ __ ] dead it ain't
coming out that brings me to dinner
strip her hair and uh
man all right i got one how old were you
when you got your passport
do you have your pants i do have my
passion for okay uh i can imagine young
kids
yeah yeah yeah you're right my mom my
mom is a very she's a nervous wreck all
the time so i'm my passport very very
wow yeah that's the first time anybody's
ever answered for paranoid reasons
oh yeah my mom we had to be out the door
in case that tenants aren't small was
that kind of a thing got kind of it
wasn't about that
it's just my mom's own neurosis like it
makes sense
yeah you know what i mean it's like she
has a tremendous amount of anxiety
just in general and then i think that
happened and then it's exacerbated so
sure well it proved it proved it you
know yeah
it's like hey horrible things happen oh
it's the last thing you need
yeah um um yeah so i had a pass for an
early age and i got a passport
now just uh with doing comedy and like
uh i had to get one recently
maybe a couple years ago uh it almost
expired and i was gonna do a weekend in
calgary or something like that okay i
was like i had to make sure i had it
yeah hmm i think i was 18.
i still don't have one oh yeah i
remember
i ain't going anywhere why should you
greatest country on earth that's right
yeah i remember like my picture on the
passport like i was young like
that picture was i was super young oh
man yeah
that's weird that is weird especially
because italians hit puberty at like 12
so you were probably like
you you like showed up to the boat or
you had a full beard on it it's like a
little kid in the picture plus the name
on it's larry jones
he's got like four of them he's like
wait who am i today well mr ricky
convertible
glad to have you in our country mr papa
giorgio
oh that's ricky convertible
i got nothing else my [ __ ] case is
closed and i'm saying
ah it's fake i don't know i'm on there
should i have your mouth shut about the
stripper thing
really yeah you're garbage buddy
yeah all right yeah yeah well you know
happy
he's not super he's not classy let's put
it you know
you're in the middle you're sure yeah
lean garbage let's do a couple of
tie breakers do you keep your toothpaste
you brush your teeth in the shower
no very nice well that sounds fun no
it's not stay away
where do you keep the butter at your
house you keep it on the counter you
keep it in the fridge
oh keep it in the fridge it's all right
okay it's good
what uh growing up did you drink milk
for dinner
huh yeah
times times water was every night i
wasn't allowed soda and i think probably
milk on like friday
friday week milk was a weekend drink
take the edge off after a long week in
the cellar
what an episode holy [ __ ] yeah the
one-man show
just so everybody knows so when the
pandemic is over anthony's going to be
performing it he was performing it
before the pandemic is called
my dad isn't danny devito by anthony
devito
whenever you [ __ ] see that on social
media i'm telling you right now you got
a glimpse of it today
go see that [ __ ] show go see it
unbelievable thanks man yeah you guys
are great man that was great i just love
you guys
thanks buddy anything else you want the
folks out there to know other than the
rad dude podcast social media just uh
uh yeah listen to my podcasts the rad
dude casts i do it with brendon air greg
stone
super fun yeah that's right check out
stoney
uh somewhat of a italian yes yeah he's
got
he's got he's got a mixed bag himself
yeah he was trash
well we grew up in the same town yeah
yeah you guys were like old school
friends yeah we knew each other from uh
high school
middle school yeah so stone knew all
this
he did a little later on in life but he
did yes wow
that's interesting yeah and he would
have another guy keep his mouth shut too
oh definitely stone he's a vault he's
evolved you're not getting anything out
of him
he lives to be that kind of friend you
know what i mean like yeah he really
gets awful being a good friend yeah yeah
yeah
absolutely um but uh yeah listen to uh
rad dudecast wherever you get podcasts
follow the podcast on instagram
at the rad dude cast and uh yeah check
out my album dream occupation
and uh thanks a lot awesome awesome
kippy what do you got as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube you can
subscribe there as well we appreciate
that and then [ __ ] patreon baby
uh patreon.com ru garbage three
different levels you get bonus uh
episodes
content video [ __ ] live streams the
whole [ __ ] nine yards
sign up today we appreciate all the
support guys thank you so much i'm at
cameron comedy
on all social media that's right at
foldygrams on instagram and at agefully
on ice on twitter
um we have mentioned that we did have a
december third show in atlantic city
that unfortunately has been canceled uh
we figured this was the you know the
largest way to tell other than
going to twitter followers um but yeah
the show's cancelled
well we'll we'll be making up that we
only sold two tickets so
mom and dad the show's canceled
the numbers were a little low and corona
is a little high
ah another shout out to our amazing
producer toby mcmullen toby what's your
uh instagram again
toby mcmullen follow toby toby mcmullen
the magic man the guy behind [ __ ]
t-bone are you garbage here we love you
guys
and we will see you next week peace